la date de sortie définitive du royaume
uni de l'union européenne aura lieu à la
fin de l'année mais un accord n'a
toujours pas été trouvé qui alors se
dirige-t-on vraiment vers un odile et
quels sont les blocages dans les
discussions on vous explique dans
facture si depuis le 31 janvier 2020 le
royaume uni est sorti de l'union
européenne les britanniques continuent
d'appliquer les règles européennes
pendant une période de transition qui
dure jusqu'au 31 décembre
à cette date le pays sortira donc du
marché unique
concrètement cela veut dire que les
règles de l'om c'est l'organisation
mondiale du commerce imposeront des
droits de douane et des quotas et les
conséquences économiques seront très
importantes
en moyenne ces droits de douane pas plus
lui qui ont des produits frais de la
viande
donc il ya des conséquences en octobre
une étude de l'assureur et leurs peines
analyser les pertes à 33 milliards
d'euros pour les exportations
européennes les pays les plus touchés
seraient l'allemagne les pays bas et la
france
l'économie hexagonale perdrait environ 3
6 milliards d'euros
du côté britannique le royaume uni
pourrait subir une contraction de 5% de
son pib durant les premiers mois de la
prévert excita hiver évidemment on peut
penser que c'est le revenu même si tout
le monde sera perdant dans cette
histoire
mais le royaume uni dépens contre 47 %
de ses exportations ils dépendent pour
40 et pourtant l'union européenne alors
que dans votre sens
il ya seulement 2 8% des importations
européennes
du de l'union européenne on voit bien
qu'un odile ne convient à aucune des
parties alors pourquoi personne n'arrive
à trouver d'accord
en réalité il y a trois points
d'achoppement à partir du 1er janvier la
grande bretagne veut reprendre le
contrôle de ses côtes littorales
jusque là elle les partager avec ses
partenaires européens ces eaux sont très
poissonneuses
elles sont très importantes pour les
pays voisins par exemple les pêcheurs
français ils réalisent 30% de leurs
prises si les européens en sont exclus
la concurrence sera féroce et les
réserves de poissons beaucoup moins
forte dans les zones communautaires nous
faut impérativement un dur s'ils
attaquent dire que ce soit pour euronor
aussi bien que pour la flottille locale
s'est cependant assuré
comme vous l'a dit monsieur le dessus et
s'enfonçant de leur activité sur la
flottille attisé aragon la porter à 70 %
mais après si on sera tous dans les eaux
françaises
on va se retrouver avec des belges des
hollandais un peu d'espagnol donc il va
y avoir une surexploitation de la
ressource et fausses sur toute fin on
est une surexploitation de la région le
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes clément boon a déjà averti
que la france opposera son veto à tout
accord qui celui-ci ne répond pas à ses
exigences sur la pêche
en grande bretagne le sujet à une valeur
politique très forte pour boris johnson
pour bruce johnson dire voilà on a
repris le contrôle de nos zoo c'est une
victoire le proclamer sur un quai d'un
port britannique au 1er janvier
évidemment c'était une parlant que
d'expliquer que sur les règles de la
concurrence équitable on a réussi telle
ou telle chose
ça parle beaucoup plus aux électeurs la
tâche et d'un point de vue français
aussi haut s'il n'est pas qu'elles n'ont
pas que des directions
quand même
bientôt en france aussi je l'allais le
gouvernement peut pas se permettre
d'avoir l'air d'abandonner ses pêcheurs
con parce qu'on parle de la pêche est
bien moins un point très sensible
politiquement et symboliquement mais qui
n'est pas le point majeur de labeur
économiquement ça ne représente quand
même pas énormément par rapport aux par
rapport au reste par contre le vrai
point crucial qui est très important
parce que ça engage vers la scion entre
les deux pays et l'avenir de la grande
bretagne sur des décennies ces fameuses
règles de concurrence équitables
deuxième obstacle la concurrence
déloyale hors de lui et le royaume-uni
est en principe indépendante des normes
européennes sur l'environnement sur le
droit du travail ou encore la fiscalité
mais bruxelles refuse de voir une
économie dérégulée à ses portes rien
n'empêchera le gouvernement de sa
majesté de subventionner des industries
privées ce que la commission européenne
interdit au nom de la concurrence
elle veut des garanties troisième
désaccord le mécanisme d'arbitrage dans
les cas de divergence lui eux souhaitent
pouvoir recourir à des contre mesures
immédiates avant même une procédure
d'arbitrage classique ce que londres
rejettent quelle instance arbitrera les
cas de violation de l'accord
normalement la cour de justice de
l'union européenne est habilité à
trancher mais la grande bretagne a
quitté le elle ne se considère plus lié
aux lois européennes
malgré ces désaccords il ya eu une
petite éclaircie dans les négociations
le 8 décembre le gouvernement
britannique retirer son projet de loi
sur le marché intérieur qui fâchent et
bruxelles celui ci remettait en cause la
liberté de circulation entre l'irlande
et l'irlande du nord fragilisant les
accords de paix négociée en 1998 une
tentative d'ouverture qui n'est
peut-être pas dénués d'arrière pensées
c'est une ombre au moins un nuage de
moins après on peut le voir des deux
côtés pour aller vers un accord
[Musique]
cela permettra au cas d'un accord
organique de 0 c de la peau d'une
européenne sinon en cas d'échec on va
nous accuser tient un accord est trouvé
pourra-t-on le ratifier avant le 31
décembre on en est loin
il faut d'abord que le texte négocié par
la commission européenne soit acceptée à
l'unanimité des 27 une condition
obligatoire
or entre la traduction dans les
différentes langues européennes et la
ratification par le parlement européen
la fenêtre de tir est vraiment très
courte une autre idée est fait alors son
chemin
ce qui commence à se dire c'est qu'il
est tout à fait possible à ce que ça se
dire à bruxelles c'est qu'il est tout à
fait possible au peigne hommes ont-ils
enfin si on devait avoir un deal il
serait tout à fait possible au passe par
une période durant laquelle on est des
tarifs au mca ce qu'on aurait peut-être
à le monde de ratifier bouclé toute
cette procédure avant le 31 décembre
[Musique]
ma